welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and this is a breakdown of peacemaker
episode 7 stop dragging my heart around
so let's just go ahead and dive into all
those neat little easter eggs and
details that you missed from yet another
banger of a peacemaker episode by siri
showrunner james gunn and of course the
title of the episode stop dragging my
heart around is of course a reference to
the stevie nick song stop dragging my
heart around but with dragon in this
case referring to this episode's formal
debut of auggie smith's white dragon
character the famed dc racist
supervillain and right away at the start
of the episode we are greeted with the
sounds of motley crue's home sweet home
which is exactly how episode 6 ended
with peacemaker playing his own piano
rendition before being framed by the
homie adebayo with the words my heart is
like an open book for the world to read
symbolically referring to christopher's
fake diary that was just revealed to the
world and these words lead us to this
opening shot of young chris and his
brother keith vibing out to albums like
theater of pain by motley crew rock and
roll over by kiss after verner by zz top
and of course look what the cat dragged
in from poison that peacemaker suggested
be played in the task force truck in
episode 5. and i also thought it was a
really clever choice to let vigilante's
knocks on the door lead into the very
beat of peacemaker's theme song at the
beginning of the episode
[Music]
and i also noticed that when white
dragon and the tiki torch whites that
peacemaker's dad augie in addition to
being a racist genius of an inventor
also is an experienced software coder
with the gps inside of the helmets
running on augiesoft version 3.0 well i
guess your dad is pretty brainy for a
racist and also i'm kind of seeing a
little theme going on with economos's
deadly animal themed t-shirts throughout
the course of this series because in
this episode economos wears the t-shirt
of a jellyfish potentially one of the
deadliest creatures in the world
depending on the species like a
jellyfish can kill multiple people if it
wants to before of course gunning down
all the white dragons walmart warriors
much like he wore a wolf t-shirt when he
used a chainsaw to release his own inner
wolf and charlie the gorilla's inner
organs and when harcourt confronts
adebayo for betraying a fellow soldier
i'm not the one who just betrayed one of
our own it's okay to shoot an innocent
man begging for his life but this you
have an issue with he is a fellow
soldier this is also reflected later on
in the episode when golf master general
squishes the mern butterfly firmly known
as iknow block in cold green blood
really driving home the fact that this
whole butterfly invasion is really just
a sort of secret intergalactic war being
fought in the shadows a situation that
leota likens to the 1996 film mars
attacks i didn't know that i was gonna
get caught up in mars attacks but my god
was i not prepared for the emotionality
that i was going to experience watching
merton's tiny little butterfly hand
clutch harcourt's finger as he slowly
passed away
but it did serve as a really awesome and
wholesome passing of the torch of team
leader which parkour ends up accepting
by episodes n mirroring the role of like
suicide squad leader that her
counterpart had in the comic and also
before getting their asses handed to
them by a judo master filled with the
fiery rage of justice and flaming hot
cheetos the last thing that these two
jerks ironically talk about before their
surprise trip to the evergreen emergency
room is their love of vigilante justice
in 1999's the boondock saints bet you
guys ain't never seen lucky the leopard
can't do that
hey speaking of judo master sure it's
fun seeing this certified badass where
her superhero costume and eating flaming
hot cheetos every time he appears in an
episode basically but i have a feeling
that judo master does this intentionally
probably as a way to deter the
butterflies that he was willingly
working with from entering his body
because the butterflies probably don't
like the volcano levels of hotness of
flaming hot cheetos as ridiculous as
that sounds and since his suit does in
fact keep his booty hole protected at
all times i think that his suit and
these flaming hot cheetos are judo
master's way of protecting himself
there's a method to this master's
martial madness now if you have multiple
credit card balances each month and are
only paying the minimums barely making a
dent in your credit card debt it can be
discouraging but upstart can help you
pay your existing debt quickly so you
can feel like you're finally getting
ahead whether you're paying off credit
card debts consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows that you are
more than just your credit score so
rather than looking at your credit score
alone upstart's model considers other
factors like your income employment and
other information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan and you can check out your
rate without impacting your credit score
in just like five minutes for loans
between 1000 to fifty thousand dollars
and you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
so find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description below that's
upstart.com new rockstars and don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you and loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and other certain information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
rock stars and i really enjoyed how the
white dragon comes into the scene by
timing the ramming of the truck to the
come on come on come on from wigwams in
my dreams
but not as much as i loved the imagery
of a bunch of dumb criminals chasing a
raccoon around the woods much like yondu
and the ravagers did with raka raccoon
on their heart in james guns guardians
of the galaxy vol 2. and then when
vigilante steals one of these racist
rednecks cars the license plate can be
read one for wrds
or 14 words which has been a rallying
cry for all the crybaby racists of the
world since 1995 by former american
domestic terrorist white supremacist
group the order but they're not around
anymore because they suck needless to
say economos did the world a favor and
peacemaker really should save his face
exercises for someone who deserves it
but before auggie dies i really enjoyed
how chris calls his dad a mother
technically
that's pretty accurate unless augie grew
chris out of the lab oh my god did he do
that but it further drives from the idea
that these racists are very much driven
by the cult-like ideology that is
currently allowing peacemakers fake
diary of conspiracy theories to be
believed hook line and sinker because he
basically grew up around all these
weirdos and auggie's mention of the
biblical story of god's testing of
abraham where you know god basically
tells abraham to sacrifice his son isaac
from genesis chapter 22 as well as the
mention of the demonic occult deity
before it while he was preaching to his
cults of the soon-to-be slain further
proves this because he very much has a
lot of this religious lexicon in his
mind because they're just a bunch of
crazy people and that of course happens
right before vigilante saves the day by
stabbing the white dragon in those gaps
in the armor that he told peacemaker
about in episode 4. there are gaffes in
the armor your dad's white dragon
costume right there are weak points
where the cloth is a fantastic callback
to earlier in the season but definitely
not as emotionally touching as eagerly
hugging peacemaker again like he did in
episode 1 after the big bird lord in the
sky returned him to this mortal plane
praise eagle jesus hallelujah however
what was super notable to me about
peacemaker's prayer at posimon
veterinary clinic where the vets are
apparently both kinds of vets and are
always ready to roll let's do this [ __ ]
is that peacemaker says that he believed
that eagerly and his dead brother keith
were the only two people that actually
loved him confirming that peacemaker
really does not mistake vigilante's
obsession with him for genuine love and
of course after vigilante completely
misinterprets the ending to 1969's butch
cassidy and the sundance kid there's a
freeze frame we hear a bunch of bullets
that doesn't mean they died yes it does
i don't think so i think they jumped
over those bullets right after that
freeze frame well that's an exceedingly
optimistic interpretation while
harcourt's team plans to kill the cow at
coverdale likely named after a favored
poet of james guns david coverdale we of
course get yet another iconic james gunn
slow walk from a superhero team because
if there isn't a dramatic slow walk with
a cute animal in it did james even gun
and finally this peacemaker episode ends
with the butterflies beating team
peacemaker to the biggest cow that i
have ever seen outside of your
grandmother's nursing home bedroom it's
a pretty big cow but
gosh just by judging by the brief
reaction that we get from this alien
life form at the end of this episode i'm
getting big time starro vibes from this
giant celestial being held against their
will and i have a feeling that
peacemaker's big goth saving heart will
not be able to kill a cow that didn't
has to be in his current abusive
situation much like he himself didn't
ask to be the son of the abusive white
dragon but that is it for our breakdown
of this episode 7 of peacemaker thank
you guys so much for watching this video
you can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] but more importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
social media and if you do that on
youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a new
video and again please hit up
newrockstarsmerch.com for amazing shirts
like this peacemaker shirt but anyways
thank you guys again for watching this
video i love you guys so much and i
appreciate you spending some time with
me i'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you